welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer networks
part two naming so in the last video we
saw how we can connect different
computers together
and we can combine networks into
internetworks
and so we're done right our computers
are hooked together
we can connect networks from one side of
the country to the next
we're all set well not exactly
let's just take an example from our
small classroom network
so as we saw in the last video the wi-fi
network in a classroom could be
considered a star network
where the wireless router is the central
hub and each student's laptop
is one of the outside nodes
now when i was in college i actually got
busted passing notes in a class
the sad thing is i wasn't even in the
class
i went to the class because a girl who i
thought was really cute
invited me to sit in with her in her
class
and we got busted passing notes but the
good news is
30 years later we're still best friends
but that won't happen to you guys
because
you guys can just text each other i
won't even know you're doing it
so let's say you're in the classroom and
you want to type a message
and here's our message here notice the
use of the
unicode heart emoji you now know how
that works internally
from the first lecture so let's say we
want to send this
message to a friend who's across the
classroom
so go ahead and type in the message and
then
wait a minute so our computers are all
hooked together but we have no way of
identifying each of the individual
computers
so in order for me to send this message
to a specific computer as opposed to
everybody in the classroom
although this is a fine message for
i would need a way of identifying
individual computers on the network so
this is the main topic of today's video
how are we going to name or identify
computers on
the network and it turns out there are a
couple different naming schemes
the first naming scheme is something
called a physical address or a mac
address
mac in this case does not stand for
macintosh it actually stands for media
access control but
i wrote that in really small font
because you don't really need to know
that
most people don't um so this is an
example of a physical address or a mac
address again those two names are
synonymous
and you can see it consists of an a
sequence of
what kind of look like numbers but
they've kind of got letters mixed in
so these are hexadecimal numbers so
they're base 16
instead of base 10 or base 2 and they're
very easy to convert from
hexadecimal to binary which is why
computer scientists like to use them
okay so
zero zero zero one forty two af three b
o five and that's our mac address for
our computer
and these are sometimes written with
dashes between them and occasionally
you'll see them written with columns
between them this is actually one of the
numbers that you provide to stanford
when you register a device with a
stanford network
it's actually how stanford realizes that
your computer is
okay to let on the network okay there's
a couple things about physical or mac
addresses first of all
of course every computer needs a unique
mac address so these are all unique
numbers
the second thing is that first set of
six hexadecimal digits those are
actually
a manufacturing prefix and so
here are some of apple's prefixes they
actually have quite a few they have over
two dozen but
here's some examples so if you've got a
mac address that starts zero zero zero a
nine five zero zero one six cb
zero zero two one e9 we know that you
have a macintosh computer
and here are some of samsung's addresses
so you get the basic
idea every manufacturer has a whole
bunch of prefixes
and whenever they create a computer or
tablet or smartphone
they use a mac address that starts with
their prefix
and i should also mention that most
computers actually have multiple mac
addresses so
you might have one mac address for your
wi-fi you might have a different mac
address for bluetooth
and if your computer actually hooks to
ethernet you would have a third mac
address for that
i can use this to get my message
from my computer to my friend's computer
across the classroom and this works
great
so are we done well not yet so
it turns out there's a problem with this
so here we've got a bunch of computers
being manufactured by apple and they're
coming off the assembly line
you can see they all share the same set
of numbers except for that last digit is
changing and so
basically you come up with another
device you change the last digit of the
number you come from the device you come
you change the last digital last number
so that's great
that does come with a whole bunch of
unique numbers for all the apple
computers which is what you need
but here's the thing these computers are
going to go to different locations
one of them might go to stanford when i
might go to the university of texas
one might go to harvard one of them
might get lucky and go off to europe
so if we use these mac addresses
to send messages across the internet
that would be like the postal service
using social security numbers to send
letters
social security numbers are unique so if
we use them to address letters there's
no ambiguity we know exactly who that
letter is supposed to go to
and so here i've got three letters
it turns out their love letters not
because i'm romantic but because
i thought it would be easier to use an
emoji than to draw a letter it turns out
i guess the only emoji for letters is
the love letter emoji
and so if we handed these three letters
to the post office gave them the social
security number of the three people we
wanted to send them to
the post office will look at us and say
what are you crazy
so clearly the system doesn't work and
in the same way
delivering messages across the internet
using mac addresses doesn't work because
the mac address has nothing to do with
where that computer is located it's a
unique number based on where that
computer was manufactured not where it
is right now
so it doesn't work very well it will
work for a small local area network so
it can work in the classroom effect
um a lot of the the small networks
actually do use the mac addresses
directly for this purpose
but we need another system to get
messages across the wider network as
opposed to
within a single network
so i do want to make it clear that the
mac addresses are used
they're just used within the local
network so they're an important
component
but they are not sufficient by
themselves if we want to get a message
outside of our local network okay so
here's our next
naming scheme these are called ip
addresses
or ip numbers the ip stands for internet
protocol and that actually is going to
turn out to be important so
i wrote that with a slightly larger font
but we'll be talking about internet
protocol in quite some detail
next lecture okay so
the traditional ip addresses ip numbers
look like this
there's four digits separated by dots
and each of the digits goes between 0
and 255
and if you think about it why do we go
from 0 to 55
because that's the range of values we
can store on a byte so really what these
ip addresses are they're four bytes
now there's a little problem with this
traditional ip address
which is if i've got four bytes
i can store 2-32 different combinations
which gives me a little over 4 billion
combinations
and there are 7.8 billion people on the
planet
so we don't have enough ip addresses for
everyone
and what's more many of you including me
have multiple ip addresses because
everything that we've got connected to
the internet needs one so if you've got
a cell phone and a laptop
well that's two you've got a smart tv
that's three you got a tablet that's
four
you've got a gaming console that's five
and then one more thing is
these numbers were not handed out
equitably
so it turns out that stanford university
was one of the first
four sites on the original internet when
the internet was first developed
and we had a huge range of numbers and
so we actually gave a bunch of
numbers away a while back because we
didn't need our full range of numbers
but
ultimately this is clearly a problem and
this scheme can't stand so
there's a newer version of ip
and it uses addresses that look like
this
and these look kind of scary to me so if
they look scary to you they look scary
to me
these consist of eight sets of
16 bits each each single hexadecimal
digit corresponds to four bits
so two sets of hexadecimal digits
corresponds to a byte
and since these are each four sets of
hexadecimal digits they're each 16 bits
and there are eight of them
so it turns out there's a total of 128
bits here
and if we do the math again with our
traditional system
we have 32 bits spread across 4 bytes
we have 232 combinations so we have a
little over 4.2
billion combinations with a new scheme
we have 228 which if you work it out as
3.4 times 10 to the 38. how big is that
well 10 to the 38 is a 1
followed by 38 0. so this is a really
really really big
number and so we should be fine even if
you guys end up with way more than
the three or four ip addresses that you
need now
in the future so the original scheme is
called ipv4 and it's still quite widely
used
but the sooner or later we do need to
move everything over to this new version
the new version is called ipv6
now here's the thing
our previous scheme the mac address also
known as physical addresses
gave each computer a unique number
and the ip addresses are going to do the
same thing
but whereas the mac or physical
addresses
were assigned by the computer
manufacturer
the ip addresses are going to be
assigned by your internet service
provider
so this isn't going to be like the post
office where we're trying to send things
using social security numbers instead
what we're going to do is we're going to
take our ip address and i'm using the
traditional ipv4
both because i'm way more comfortable
reading them and
it's much easier not using those super
super super long numbers for our
examples okay so here's
here's a letter we're trying to send on
the internet we've got this ip number
181.12.83.0
i look at the first two digits there
181.12
and i immediately know that that is a
stanford university ip
address remember i told you we have a
whole bunch of ip addresses
more than we need it so this is a part
of the range that we kept
and so i know
it's in the united states i know it's
stanford university but i actually know
more than that
if i look at the 1812 and then i look at
the
83 i actually know it's gavel on dorm
i'm using galvan for example because
that's where i was as a resident fellow
for 12 years okay so i can get to that
particular dorm
and so you can see that we can route it
not only to the internet service
provider but the internet service
provider can set up their system so that
they can route it even further within
the system down to the point where
the routing software can just keep track
of of this particular person
here's their mac address i actually know
where that mac address is located
and so this system will work to route
anything
within the internet now keep in mind
since these numbers
are related to your internet service
provider if you have a particular number
here when you're at stanford
and let's say you fly home and you're
now on comcast
you're going to get a different ip
address
we're not done yet the problem is these
ip addresses
are not very easy to remember there are
some people that know a bunch of ipv4
addresses
mostly computer tech people there are
certain ipv4 addresses on campus that
they need to know
but i'm rather doubtful anybody has any
of these ipv6 addresses memorized so
this is not not sufficient so we need
another scheme
and that is host names and this is what
you guys are used to so
like www.stanford.edu
www.nasa.gov
all those addresses that you are used to
those are called host names
and there's a system to convert from a
host name to an ip address
ultimately all traffic on the internet
travels using the ip addresses
we've got one other major naming system
to talk about
and while the previous naming systems
were used to identify computers on the
internet
this particular naming system is used to
identify programs running on a single
computer
so here's my computer here and i'm
running a number of different programs
i'm running a web browser i'm running an
email program i'm running a messaging
system and i'm streaming music
and so my computer is receiving
information from lots of different
computers out on the internet
and so when my computer receives that
information it needs to figure out which
one of the various programs
that i'm running that information should
be sent to and that's what this
port number system is used for so here's
some common port numbers
uh web browsing uses port 80. email uses
port 143
actually email has several different
ports associated with it facebook
messaging uses port 522
and so on so if my computer receives
data and it's marked with port 143 my
computer knows that
that should be forwarded on to the email
program
whereas if my computer receives
information marked with port 3689 it
knows that that
goes to the music program and if it gets
information with port 80 it knows that
it should go to the web browser
you may run into these port numbers
particularly
in relationship to computer security
the firewall would turn these ports on
or off and we'll talk about that when we
get to the security lecture but
essentially what's happening here is
with the firewall is
it's controlling what information goes
out of the computer and what information
comes onto the computer based on the
port number so it says
oh you don't use this particular port
maybe this is the standard port that's
used for for a particular program but
you're not using that program so if i
start receiving traffic to your computer
trying to get through that port
it's probably somebody trying to hack
the program associated with that port or
somehow use some sort of
vulnerability in the software to to get
into your computer so i'm going to go
ahead and block that port
and you're only going to turn on the
ports that you actually need for the
programs that you're running
you may also hear the term socket this
is related
essentially a socket is a connection
between two computers
um so you can see here i've got a web
server
this web server has sockets open to
three different computers
i've got a line drawn showing a single
one of these sockets where
the web server is communicating with
124.12.0.152 that's my ip address and
it's on port 80
and then i would have different sockets
open to these other computers that
my web server is sending information to
all right that's it for today but we
will continue taking a look at the
internet
in the next lecture i'll see you then
you